as president Trump was leaving Singapore
I talked with him aboard Air Force One
about the summit and what's next that
summit was highly produced and
choreographed down to a very specific
pitch meant to appeal to the movie
loving pop culture obsessed kim jung-han
[Music]
after the pool cameras left the
bilateral meeting president Trump and
his team pulled out an iPad to show the
North Korean dictator and his team a
highly produced four-minute video put
together by the National Security
Council Destiny Pictures presents a
story of opportunity a news story
one of peace to men
one destiny
a story about a special moment in time
when a man is presented with one chance
that may never be repeated
what will these shoes to show vision and
leadership or not there can only be two
results one of moving back
[Music]
or one of moving forward the slick movie
trailer was then shown to attacked news
conference I hope you liked it I thought
it was good I showed it to him today
actually during the meeting toward the
end of the meeting and I think he loved
it about eight of their representatives
who are watching it and I thought they
were fascinated but I thought it was
well done the president then spent more
than an hour answering journalists
questions more than three dozen of them
even mentioning the specific real estate
pitch he used with Kim Jong on they have
great beaches you see that whenever
they're exploding their cannons into the
ocean right if I said boy look at that
wouldn't that make a great condo beyond
and I explained I said you know instead
of doing that you could have the best
hotels in the world right there think of
it from a real estate perspective from
the press conference on sentosa island a
20-minute motorcade to an airbase in
Singapore to board his ride home Air
Force One
thanks for the time what is this 26
hours 20 I'm now on my 26th we've been
negotiating with some very good
negotiators nice to be with you thank
you for having us but you took every
question in the news conference so I
took a lot of them and we had a lot of
reporters I don't know if you saw that
room but the credentials were like
record ton of numbers and I took as many
as I could people are really happy about
it even I would say non Trump fans that
people are really happy it's something
that I'm very proud of now with that
being said I want to get it done but I
believe that chairman Kim wants to get
it done you do I mean I do there was one
part of the news conference I think you
were kind of joking that six months from
now you could say this is a mistake and
I'm never gonna tell you that and I
couldn't happen I mean all of a sudden
well you don't believe that it's deals
whether it's this which is so important
or buying a building or doing whatever
you may be doing no I don't think that's
gonna happen but I said you know I only
consider it successful if it gets done I
think we've done something very historic
already in one way but to me a success
is when it gets done is the military
drawing down
in South Korea you kind of hinted at
that and is there going to be this count
tit-for-tat no it's not drawing down at
all in fact honestly was never discussed
I'm sure he'd like that it was never on
the table we you know when when I met
him today would have a very good
relationship I feel I feel good you know
we know when we have chemistry you know
it as well as anybody and you understand
what I mean but when I met him today we
had done three months almost four months
worth of work prior to my meeting so we
sort of understood that was never on the
table with that being understood and and
you know you ask me a question like that
I would love to get the military out as
soon as we can because it costs a lot of
money a lot of money for us we don't get
paid fully for that military which you
know I'll be talking to South Korea
about but we have 32,000 soldiers in
South Korea I'd like to get them home I
would like to but it is not on the table
right now at the appropriate time it
will be what do you think China looks at
this and says well this is kind of what
we want you know with Korea that's under
control a u.s. that's maybe disengaging
from the region no I think China really
would like to see no nuclear weapons you
want to know the truth because look
whether your semi friendly with the
nation or not when they have nuclear
weapons and you're that close it can't
be a positive feeling it just can't be
so China's been very helpful I think
over the last two months maybe less so I
think the border got a little bit more
open now
it didn't affect today's negotiation but
I think that water opened up a little
bit more because China could be a little
bit upset about trade because we're very
strongly clamping down on trade how
strong well I think very strongly I mean
you'll see over the next couple of weeks
we've they understand what we're doing
with that being said have a very good
relationship with President Xi of
Chinese you know incredible guy they
just you know essentially president for
life yeah that's pretty good
so North Korea you know they've agreed
to things before they've agreed to
several things but that's with a
different president and nobody's taking
it this far and presidents have never
met with anybody from North Korea it's
been you know delegated to other people
and even if they did meet they wouldn't
have been able to pull it off but this
is something that should have been done
years ago I mean you've heard me say it
many times this should have been done 10
years 15 20 years ago this shouldn't be
done now where they have an arsenal of
nuclear weapons I should have never
allowed to get to this point with that
being said chairman Kim wants to resolve
the problem because he knew that we
weren't playing around I wasn't playing
around he's not playing around we have a
very I really say for you know for a
fairly short term relationship because
it was unbelievably hostile the rhetoric
rhetorically it was unbelievably hostile
and I think we have a very good
relationship we understand each other
you know you were asked in the press
conference a number of different times
in different ways about human rights and
you know that you called this
relationship really good and that he was
talented person you know you call people
sometimes killers you know he is a
killer
he's always executing people hey when
you take over a country tough country
tough people and you take it over from
your father I don't care who you are
what you are how much of an advantage
you have if you could do that at 27
years old you I mean that's one in
10,000 that could do that so he's a very
smart guy it's a great negotiator but I
think we understand each other
but him he still some done some really
bad things yeah but so have a lot of
other people done some really bad things
I mean I could go through a lot of
nations where a lot of bad things were
done now look with all of that being
said the answer is yes I'm going from
today I'm going from maybe 90 days ago
because we really started this we got a
call that he was going to the Olympics
he would like to go to the Olympics and
that was sort of the beginning of what
we have right now and we were very far
down the line
you saw the agreement nobody thought we
were going to have an agreement like
that
and things were given to me as you know
from the news conference things were
given to me Brett that were not even
part of the agreement I got them after
we had signed the agreement and so
verification you're confident you can
set up a simply confident then if we
can't we can't have a deal we have to be
you know it has to be verified but one
of the things that really I'm happy is
that the soldiers that died in Korea
their remains are going to be coming
back home and we have thousands of
people that have asked for that
thousands and thousands of people so
many people asked when I was on the
campaign I'd say wait a minute I don't
have any relationship but they said when
you can president would love our son to
be brought back home you know their
remains and I asked we had pretty much
finished and I said would you do me a
favor the remains of these great fallen
heroes can we do something he agreed to
it immediately it's pretty great
why do you think him raised to complete
his nuclear program and then decide to
give it up and psychologically he felt
it was important and I understand that
but again this should not have been
happening now this should have happened
years ago and and I'm not blaming
President Obama I'm saying
during Obama during Bush during Clinton
this should have happened Clinton got
played I mean when you look at what
happened he get billions of dollars and
it was like just a total waste of money
so does this summit thing you seem like
you like it and interacting with these
world leaders g7 got a little rocky
there was a question about that you left
the g7 summit a few days ago in Canada
having determined that Prime Minister
Trudeau is weak and dishonest what do
you say to America's allies who worried
that you might be jeopardizing our
long-term alliances and who worried that
you might be treating our historic
friends as enemies and our historic
enemies as friends I had a very good
meeting with the g7 and I left the
meeting and I'll be honest we are being
taken advantage of by virtually every
one of those countries very first
seriously and we're being taken
advantage of on trade it really wasn't
rocky when I left it was great in fact I
spoke to Prime Minister Abbey it was
great when I left I spoke to him just
recently I just told him about what had
happened and he said it's amazing
because he left it was like fine I
negotiated a different kind of a deal
than they wanted but I was okay with it
I thought
then I saw what took place at this news
conference I said that is not really
what happened so does this make you want
to sit down with Vladimir Putin no but
the question was asked by a reporter it
used to be the g8 Russia was included
and about four or five years ago they
expelled Russia and a reporter asked me
do you think you'd be better off with
Russia I said absolutely you know we
spend probably 25% of our time talking
about Russia and I said to myself would
it be better if they were here no I'm
not for Russia I'm for the United States
as an example if Vladimir Putin were
sitting next to me at a table instead of
one of the others and we were having
dinner the other night in Canada I could
say we do to me a favor would you get
out of Syria would you do me a favor
would you get out of the Ukraine get out
of Ukraine you shouldn't be there just
come on get now I think I'd probably
have a good relationship with them or
I'd be able to talk to him better than
if you call somebody on a telephone
until if I'm sitting like I was with the
others for instance the new Prime
Minister of Italy he is a great guy we
had a great relationship he agrees with
me and Putin by the way I have to tell
you but this wasn't anything that was up
for vote this was a reporter asking a
question I said yeah I think you're
better off as a g8 better than a g7 and
a lot of people agree with me but I will
tell you as an example if if he were at
that meeting
I could ask him to do things that are
good for the world that are good for our
country that is good for him despite all
that he's done to us you think he's
gonna he didn't I'm not I'm not sticking
up for anybody I'm just saying this he
didn't respect our leadership previously
he walked all over them look what he did
to Obama with Crimea he took Crimea he
took Ukraine he I mean sections of
Ukraine which is why I got kicked out of
the gia no I know but he didn't respect
our leadership he didn't respect it and
so but this wasn't me you know people
say well look what he did he did it to
Obama Obama should not have allowed that
to happen even with the voter stuff
supposedly the FBI went to Obama they
told him about it he didn't do anything
about it do you think the North Korea
this few days here has changed the
dynamic in the midterm elections and
today where do you think the midterm
elections in your head are so Brett I
saw a new show and I've seen 120 days
ago we were down 16 points now I see
reuters has us up two and another one
was up six and when it was down three I
think it's a whole different ballgame I
think the economy is so good I think the
tax cuts have been incredible far
greater than even I thought they'd be
the regulation cuts have been great I've
done more in five hundred days than any
president has ever done in their first
five hundred days there's nobody close
and that's not that's a lot of people
saying that's people that would rather
not say it or saying it
and I really think that wouldn't do very
good now history is against me because
history up for whatever reason you win
the election and then you'll lose lots
of seats I think we're gonna do very
well I really do I think the economy is
doing so well we're doing so well as a
nation I think we're gonna surprise
people and if you look at the numbers
and if you look at the kind of turnouts
like Texas how many people showed up to
vote as an example how many Republicans
showed up to vote people were very
surprised
mr. president you people are a little
tired because they can't hang with you
26 hours so we're gonna wrap it up there
I'm very impressed because we're holding
up Air Force wonder for you I know thank
you sir good that's a big plate I'd be
over the time thank you very much thank
you very much for a depreciating we
appreciate the time mr. president you're
welcome back any time on special report